das deutsche institut für normung hat
gerade vorgeschlagen die offizielle
deutsche buchstabiert tafel nach dem 5 0
09 zu ändern und aus vornamen
städtenamen zu machen also wie anton a
wie augsburg hintergrund ist dass die
nazis alle jüdischen vornamen aus der
tafel getilgt hatten aus samuel machten
sie siegfried aus nathan wurde nordpol
nun könnte man die alten namen wieder
einsetzen aber dann sind es zu viele
männer und was ist dann mit anderen
religionen es ist nicht so einfach denn
wäre ein mw mohammed angebracht das sagt
zb der kolumnist harald martenstein und
er führt weiter aus dass man dann aber
auch ost west unterschiede bei den
städten wiederum berücksichtigen müsste
also auch einen zivi sind die anführen
sollte cwg übrigens auch nicht mehr weil
bei korean kolonialistischer hintergrund
festgestellt worden sei pizza margarita
denkt man das müsste klappen ist aber
auch problematisch weil die
namensgeberin eine italienische könig
gehen muss linie das nahe stand und weil
auch hawaii offenbar ein wort mit
kolonialistisch im hintergrund sei wurde
die umbenennung in pizza mit ananas
vorgeschlagen allerdings entstanden hass
der sprache der guarani insofern falle
das wort unter kulturelle aneignung es
gibt anscheinend kein ausweg mehr was
soll man ja okay ist bleibt einem nicht
mehr viel zu sagen aber kanzlerkandidat
armin laschet der hat im ersten teil zum
wahnsinn und sprechers muss folgendes
gesagt und fordert
die tassen im schrank lassen sensibel
sein für menschen die es berührt aber
wenn menschen am ende nicht mehr wissen
darf ich das noch sagen nun darf ich das
nicht sagen führt das nicht dazu das
vertrauen im staat wächst wer das klingt
eindeutig komisch nur dass ausgerechnet
jemand aus dem zukunftsteam von lasche
das offenbar anders sieht
sachsens ministerin für kultur und
tourismus nämlich barbara klepsch hat
neue fakten jetzt geschaffen die
staatliche kunstsammlung in dresden die
ihr unterstehen haben 143 kunstwerke
umbenannt aus landschaft mit
mechanischen pilgern wird landschaft mit
betenden muslimen aus schwarz
afrikanerin mit spiegel wird afrikanerin
mit spiegel und aus hund zwerg und knabe
wird rund kleinwüchsiger mann und junge
das ganze sei ein fortlaufender prozess
heißt es alle rund anderthalb millionen
objekte im bestand werden jetzt auf
rassistische oder anderweitig
diskriminierende begriffe oder inhalte
geprüft
philipp seine meinung bei uns spät
meinem chef für dpa afx der schon mit
dem kopf schüttelt also wenn ich das
höre dass aus einem
kleinem zweck jetzt ein kleinwüchsiger
man wird weil man das werk nicht mehr
sagen darf nicht mal im historischen
kontext und finde ich das einfach
kleingeistig und auch gefährlich was ist
das denn für ein vorhaben das man
anfängt systematisch kunst und
geschichte zu überprüfen da frage ich
mich nicht nur ob diese menschen zu viel
zeit haben sondern was sucht man da
sucht man rassismus ungerechtigkeit
diskriminierung antisemitismus sexismus
in der geschichte ja viel spaß die wird
man ja überall finden ich frage mich
woher kommt dieses unwohlsein und doch
die realität zu ertragen uns unsere
realität gehört ja nun mal das na ja
dass menschen nicht perfekt sind das
menschen aber auch eine tolle
entwicklung bislang durchgemacht haben
und auch bei diesen bei diesen namen wie
man jetzt buchstabieren soll usw da
frage ich mich warum ertragen wir dinge
nicht einfach warum muss man sich von
allem angegriffen fühlen ich fühle mich
ehrlich gesagt nicht angegriffen also
ich komme aus einer jüdischen familie
und es ist nicht so dass ich gerade da
sitze und mir denke mein gott warum sind
da jetzt nicht die jüdischen namen mit
denen ich buchstabieren muss sondern
deutsche mein gott es sind namen mit
denen man buchstabiert das muss doch
nicht alles auf politische norm gebracht
werden und auch die städte was ist denn
mit den städten muster auch nach proporz
sortiert werden ost west groß und klein
städte also wirklich dieser normierung
wahnsinn ist komplett außer kontrolle
geraten wie ich finde und der ist jetzt
ja hier auch endlich im fachbegriff
würde man sagen alte schinken also es
geht hier wirklich um jahrhunderte alte
gemälde die ja das widerspiegeln eine
realität von damals widerspiegeln und
eben auch in ihren titeln eine realität
von damals widerspiegeln warum sollte
man die jetzt nochmal verwischen
vereinigen ich es geht ja nicht um die
sprache wie wir sie jetzt benutzen
sondern es geht ja um eine sprache wie
sie früher benutzt wurde richtig dass
geschichtsklitterung das ist absoluter
historisch ist bei geschichte und bei
geschichtswissenschaft und auch bei
kunst wissenschaft geht es ja darum zu
erfahren was war und nicht das was war
so zu interpretieren wie man es jetzt
gerne hätte also man versucht eine
alternative realität zu erschaffen und
entfernt sich wirklich komplett von dem
was wirklich vorgefallen ist von dem man
auch zu lernen hat es gibt ja zum
beispiel auch ein kunst titel der heißt
dunkelhäutiger sklave jetzt soll das
kunstwerk nur noch sklave heißen naja
aber vielleicht hatte die dunkelhäutig
keita etwa mit dem dasein als sklave zu
tun vielleicht wurden in diesem fall ja
dunkelhäutige menschen unterdrückt
möchte ich auch nicht mehr jüdischer kz
häftling sagen sondern auch kz
häftlingen und bloß niemanden zu
diskriminieren also damit leugnet man
geschichte und ich frage mich auch wer
hat diese menschen denn ernannt ich habe
das ministerium gestern angefragt die
meinten wir haben das nicht angeordnet
und nicht durchgeführt sie verantworten
uns natürlich aber was sind das für
leute die sich selbstständig vornehmen
anderthalb millionen kunstwerke zu
prüfen nach ihren eigenen völlig
subjektiven maßstäben und den einfach
neue titel zu verleihen ich würde auch
nicht ganz billig sein nein absolut
nicht es wird in deutschland generell
sehr viel geld darin investiert dass
menschen darüber sprechen ob nicht
irgendjemand theoretisch verletzt sein
könnte aber das gehört ja ehrlich gesagt
auch zu einer gesellschaft dazu man
entwickelt sich ja genauso weiter indem
also den gesellschaft ist ja auch
dauerhafte reibung woher kommt dieses
diese idee dass das niemand sich
irgendwie ungerecht behandelt fühlen
darf dass wir leben wir leben ja nicht
in einer watte gesellschaft und erst
recht haben wir keine watte geschichte
unsere geschichte also gerade wenn man
über die deutsche wer spricht da hätte
man jetzt auch rangehen können und sagen
man streicht einfach alles was mit
nationalsozialismus zu tun hat das war
ja diskriminiert das wollen wir gar
nicht sehen aber dafür geht man doch in
museen klar wir wollen keine stadien
keine hitler start und auf den straßen
haben aber hier geht es ja auch nicht um
den öffentlichen raum wie man geht in
ein museum um zu lernen darüber wie
geschichte war und jetzt erfährt man gar
nicht mehr wie geschichte war sondern
die irgendwelche drogen ideologen sie
gerne hätten
[Musik]